jean-marc entre toi et moi déjà est ce
que tu penses que benjamin castaldi
s'est fait arnaquer par le chirurgien
qui a refait ses
jetons c'était denjean nord s'est fait
arnaquer par toute la france
si tu veux gens continuent en juin j'ai
des yeux tout le temps vers moi mais
c'est vrai que c'est compliqué non c'est
pas ça va travailler à coûter mais c'est
rare je vais vous dire la vérité je vous
le jure ça aurait rien n'a changé c'est
vrai
c'est plus ouvert même s'ils arrêtent et
n importe qu on dirait des troupes si
ça va faire péter par les yeux son char
déconner arrêté elle a son charme ça a
son charme fiona bon ça pour ça sacha
soir son charme à un petit charme c'est
vraiment castaldi non non non
jamais non pas du tout nouveau site et
préfère ressemble à bach femmes fiona ne
dit pas non plus si
la panoplie y être mais c'est vrai que
voilà c'est passé c'est pas la même
génération
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]
mais les deux sont très belles bien sûr
elle tombe enfin s'est rencontré lors de
mon premier stage chez endemol avec
aurore ah oui avec ta femme de benjamin
c'est fou elle m'a donné a dit
s'intéresser à tout ce que vous racontez
ou quoi alors est ce qu'on s'en fout un
peu merci jean marc contre toi et moi
pourquoi les audiences de tpm paix sont
toujours meilleures lorsque mathieu de
l'andorre n'est pas là
bas pour des raisons évidentes de 13 ans
de nature de leur mort est normal ça va
c'est comme ça une légende urbaine banon
on aime offenser les chiffres oui c'est
des chiffres des chiffres ce sont les
chiffres à temps tout à fait c'est un
truc
[Rires]
mais comme la demande le weekend contra
qu'un record d'audience
un gars merci jean mas jean marie entre
toi et moi petite question est ce que tu
as eu le temps de jeter un oeil sur la
nouvelle émission de la rentrée qui fait
énormément de bruit le six as et
j'ai eu le temps de regarder alors mais
j'ai éternuer je déconne généré
[Applaudissements]
seulement une question pour toi oui si
je devais en choisir qu'un la
présentation du système bernard montiel
valérie bénaïm benjamin castaldi et qu'
aucun des trois
mois je pense qu'il faut 30 nicolas
pernikoff
on leur envoie tuf à la terreur bien
hier il va revenir assez ferme en tout
cas il sera là jeudi
je la devançais
vous rendez compte de ce que vous dites
mais il va revenir nicolas théry qu'ils
adorent c'est parce que juste à fond on
est en train de voir
je me suis contenté doigts qui fait
devant sa télé mais on ya laissé un
arbre de mai qu'il m'envoie plein de slr
m'a offert un cadeau pour mon
anniversaire une raquette de paddle
magnifique si j'adore ces marbres
vouloir merci de vos amis
et bien vous aimiez vous dire on ne
m'achète pas
regardez d'ailleurs et d'apparat qui m'a
offert un cadeau ici jamais pardon ccim
sacem est à l'origine un bon cadeau à
nos fins cac me faire un cadeau potable
et pourtant tout cela appartient et
benjamins ils élaborent des cadeaux
magnifique chaque année il appelle aussi
décidé belle crème ouais c'est vrai nom
mais delphine de son cadeau paca 12
justement parlant de signes à mon frère
jean-marc entre toi et moi est ce que tu
penses que guillaume genton va enfin
réussir à pécho delphine
ouais non mais elle à quelqu'un on est
le fils non oui mais bon tu sais si dell
a la vie est courte il ya des accidents
de la vie non non non je suis je suis
pour l'amour voilà mamour et le cul
oui j'ai gagné mon pote donc vous avez
eu des nouvelles de défis de ce week-end
non non mais c'est fini la non rupture
c'est fini concernés jamais ça dure et
adulé un nom quand même à celle
enseignée dans ces cas là moi c'est fini
il a fait quoi là bas c'est fini et eva
longoria mais j'avais un calendrier
ajouté l'exemple
quelque chose mais pas du tout justement
battait comme lui il s'est fait des
films tout seul ah oui voilà il s'est
passé quelque chose s'est jamais rien
passé c'est sûr que si j'avais un
calendrier je comptais des jours et on
est en sang depuis un an grâce à sa
toiture prison connaît non mais non mais
sans égal et non c'est dingue parce que
le mec qui va le monde l intrigue les
cas vraiment heureuse c'est fou ça fait
mal a dit non oui c'est ça tu es des
couleurs qui attaquent le cerveau
artc je connais ça c'est un naturel non
plus chez moi j'embarque entre toi et
moi tu sais que je suis désormais
célibataire
j'ai pas on va passer
jean-marc entre toi et moi c'est pas
c'était quelques chroniqueurs tu ne
souhaites pas invitée à ton spectacle
koala dit la vérité on va perso j'ai pas
envie d'inviter nature il arrive
toujours à centristes et les gars
sa tablette c'est ça le problème est
exactement
jean-marc entre toi et moi est ce que
gilbert des dfa tout pour réussir à se
marier cette année au prochainement
tu vois c'est dingue d'ailleurs cette ce
week-end n'était encore pas tout non
mais c'est parce qu'elle travaillait
beaucoup mais assis tout le dimanche
j'ai pris soin d'elle oui crever des
gens comme ça allait le jour l'animal
est ouvert une boulangerie
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]
il saura que les méchants j'adore
tes mais chaudes
vous adore aussi j'adore mais d'ailleurs
faudra donner le nom ça pour lui
dans les nôtres immochan fut anobli mais
dès samedi elle travaille d'accord elle
est dans l'esthétique de l'image bull
dimanche le dimanche je me suis occupé
d'elle toute la journée elle en avait
marre le soir mais j'ai tenu bon ah oui
vous savez quoi mais moi je me suis
occupé d'elle gma c'est un peu les pieds
je vais parler beaucoup
de vies à tous si tu nous as tous si tu
nous regardes j'espère que termine la
série à heureusement qu'elle travaille
un oui à mon avis elle va pas tarder à
voir l'institut le dimanche
jean matte entre toi et moi pour le bien
des missions est ce que je dois me
séparer de bernard montiel
de bernard montiel
il reste toujours nicolas pernikoff
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]